[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Ericson alongside this guy hi I'm a
Alexander hi wow that was like a Cookie
Monster thing that what you were going
for oh yeah I'm a cookie it's it's
Christmas he's in a cookie mode is that
how you're feeling cookies he's feeling
Christmas and I am too oh my God Santa I
know him I know him listen we're
watching She's the Man we're not
watching a Christmas movie today but
it's going to be okay now you guys got
to let us know what woman in your life
is a She's the Man type and I don't know
what that question means but I would
love to know what you guys have to say
about it leave a like leave a comment
leave a comment to that answer my
question I would love to know and also
don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell gosh that was good
that so good when people join in and do
the songy singy songy singy also thanks
to prep for helping us edit down these
videos we super appreciate you also you
want to get super sexy you got to get on
patreon you can sing up with your own
copy watch with me and Aaron this whole
day she's the man but also um Greg and
John offer exclusive highlights and
watch alongs over there on patreon so
you know get sexy get on patreon do the
correct business okay we love you either
way and I think that's it like before we
get into it right are we ready okay well
we're going watch She's the
[Music]
man we trying to party H
uh we can clap to just like this song We
Will clap and sing a long yeah yeah yeah
I don't play soccer do you nope n not
even the little football me neither I'll
watch it
though inspired by the play 12th night
by Shakespeare what wow okay awesome I'm
taking you know that one that's that's
cool I mean not well at all but like I
do not I'm not even going to
front you are really getting good a you
too I mean when we first started going
out you couldn't kiss at all I Mee so
probably already better than half the
guys on my
team what do you mean I couldn't kiss at
all don't worry I taught
you is that a thing you have to like
teach him how to kiss I right you're
like well if I move my mouth this way
they'll also learn to do it this way
that's commitment if you're willing to
teach somebody to do it I'd be like no
skip it we're not dating good on you
amandine School cut our team wait what
this is not over now College Scouts they
won't even get to see us play we want to
try out for the boys team uh anything
besides that what's going on Coach girls
here want to try out for the team girls
aren't as fast as boys or strong or as
athletic oh god well Justin you're the
team captain what do you think about it
I think the coach said it all yesterday
you told me that I was better than half
the guys on your team I never said
that not a liar not a gas an a-hole to
just like throw her the bus like that
right are you lying Val end of
discussion end of
relationship I just don't want to see
you get hurt you're so full of and you
can't
kiss yeah dude get it together
[Music]
disappointment is that she's going to
become the man to play soccer Tech yeah
I hope she is to like wear a disguise
and stuff yeah that would be
ridiculous who's this girl God you and
your brother look scary alike from the
back oh my God who is that it's her from
Virgin River oh you guys she's in Virgin
River and I thought always thought like
this girl come from Virgin River I swear
to God you guys I know eron's like I
don't watch that show I've said it's a
Netflix show all right keep your eyes
closed eyes closed eyes closed close
closed closed they're closed
surprise oh God have no interest in
being a debutant how could I wind up
with a daughter who only wants to kick a
muddy ball around a field all day they
cut my team what no soccer yeah looks
like a wedding dress yeah it really does
that's what they wear at won balls it's
weird really yeah you been to one yeah
I've I've seen a a couple and they're
like they wear these yeah it's weird
Monique was looking for you why do you
even date her anyway she's hot it's a
guy thing this script is so like my God
it's very early 2000s yes it is and Mom
can't see me she thinks I'm staying at
dad's dad thinks I'm staying at Mom's
where are you going London for a couple
of weeks my band got a slot in a music
festival there like the place on your
heart love what are you going to do
about school pretend to be mom callia if
you want to chase your dreams sometimes
you got to break the rules right yeah
man rock and roll well you just talking
with your brother yes on the phone he's
at Dad's bye dad broken
sometimes I just think you just might as
well be your
brother you know what if you can't join
him my gosh this guy turned you into
your brother that's right I'm going
toyia Sebastian I'm going to make the
boys soccer team there and then in 12
days I'm going to beat the Cornwall boys
team that's right okay you know that guy
he works still now and he just looks so
young here I forget his name nobody
earlier has even met Sebastian they
wouldn't know the difference oh come on
Paul yeah come on Paul yeah come on come
on Paul yeah
Paul oh my God they do have to wear
disguises I love it I think I did forget
what 12th night by shakespear was but
there's don't do
that
God I'm going to Dad house for 2 weeks
you know that Monique is going to be
there 24/7 with Sebastian so maybe she
could show me the ropes on the whole
Deon thing F you going to be a
lady she dressed like she want to be the
vice president's wife
yeah oh it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
terrible is this our love interest and
is he new preppy oh it's it's yeah it is
okay wait are you sure I can do this oh
yeah absolutely our self-love
interest what's up oh my God you was a
good friend I did your hair and your
makeup and that was not easy that was
not easy by you're being a girl we're
not going go that was a fun shot that
was fun let me hear the voice I'm
Sebastian Now show me the
strut no hakal
Lugi I'm so proud
I can do this I am a dude I am a hunky
dude I'm a badass hunky dude yeah you
tell yourself
[Music]
yeah there's someone behind
you God is it some hot guy that's a
roommate oh my God it's chanting what's
your name Sebastian Hastings
Duke um okay that guy looks familiar do
you know when a soccer Tri start you
play absolutely Center forward you know
bro oh my
God okay why do you have tampons in your
boot uh oh they know your cover's blown
I get really bad nose
bleeds sick excuse Beckham does it all
the time seriously yes look I'll show
you how to do
[Laughter]
it and it stick right
in it absorbs right
up
they're going to try it let's start the
season how we finish the last oh I love
him yeah I can't remember what he's from
he's like the silent guy and Gone in 60
seconds with Nick Cage he doesn't say
anything and it's great don't you know
who I am wait a minute I think I do know
him yeah he's in a bunch of stuff is
that Juggernaut from X-Men Last Stand
probably is I'm the Juggernaut B shirs
and skins I have to be a shirt what I'm
allergic to the sun huh
deathly allergic how you standing there
to accommodate get your story straight
and your accent and your accent straight
Let's
Go She's the man the soundtrack is
winning winning winning us over she's
the man yeah she's the man she's the man
yeah she's the man yeah soundtrack it
soundrack it soundrack
it
wonder if Amanda binds had to get like
slightly good at soccer to or maybe she
already was good I wonder maybe now I
want to split us up into first string
and second string you second stringers
you're just as much part of this team as
the first stringers part from of course
playing the game
part hes Pensky Hastings second string
the rest of you congratulations first
stringers but I want to start dang it
her plans really not working out her
plan's ruined principal gold wants to
see you in his office MH it's done they
know that Sebastian's fire sock no it's
the stuff she has a wrap around her
boob could it be any
bigger David
Cross htio go is cross hey I'd like to
say welcome to TOA welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome
TOA do that to every student yeah I'm
doing great you know just busy being a
guy well let's take a look at your file
Sebastian you just stand there in your
cabinet not blinking strong eye contact
with all your students you being
inspired by the charcoal black and candy
apple red you know it hey don't touch it
ever I was a transfer student myself
myself so I keep a special interest on
the transfer students that come to this
school and don't be surprised if I don't
just pop in unannounced from time to
time just to check up I look forward to
it sorry what is oh getting to know the
opposite sex are we stop being weird
it's giving like Elfie impish Vibes oh
yeah yeah is he always that friendly are
you kidding that's him being rude don't
have her fall in love with you now know
right ooh cute shoes oh you think so I
got my anthropology no way they have
shoes there oh yeah right by the
accessories huh here your books why the
southern
accent I she give you the eyes okay she
likes you she lik you so the game
against cornall that should be
interesting huh my sister goes there and
she used to date that tool justtin draon
I made him cry once during a game is
your sister hot I guess so she's she's
got a great
personality
e oh my
god oh yeah check out the booty on that
Blondie uhoh don't talk about her that
way that your girl friend he wishes
until recently she was dating this
college guy but he dumped her and I hear
she's a total mess right now like really
vulnerable in man words it's time to P
exactly I can relate you know I mean I
just got out of a bad relationship too
you think you know someone you realize
it's all been a big lie every touch
every kiss what's this feeling
[__] time to play some football also
what happened to Pepsi man Pepsi's
hardcore in this film and I'm like I
haven't seen Pepsi in a minute they do
offer it a Taco Bell though they do you
should have seen 28 Days Later Pepsi was
all over that really oh yeah
Pepsi what happened to Pepsi guys it's
still out there sound off in the
comments if you like
Pepsi shout it
off shower shoes are to be worn in the
bathroom at all times except when in the
actual shower did you not re your dorm
life
pamphlet ouch that was clean that was
good o
[Music]
damn
love how dramatic it is it gets like
dark and the sky is cloudy this is
[Laughter]
insane are
you oh this is like her nightmare I got
it this is shot really cool come on baby
come
on not the Charlie Brown
no-oh my God that was such a strong
laugh right impressive oh what
the oh she's getting hazed
dang
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome God I don't want it no you must
remove your clothes remove your clothes
no can't do it she can't do that she
can't do
that
how did nobody see her yeah that's mean
there's a lot of stuff like how did the
guy not see her trying to pull out the
thing from the filing cabinet and how
did they not see her go to
that take me home and make sure I never
do anything like this again look I I
don't know what to tell you about the
whole soccer team but as for the social
stuff I got an idea you do yeah remember
those flip phones they're so nostalgic
early
2000s
how you doing baby I'm not the same
without
you I miss you
Sebastian I've been thinking about you a
lot okay did she just say that to
Sebastian what just happened big
mournful sigh sweet farewell yours play
thing baby yours play
thing you good over there guy
women yeah you
know yeah yeah yeah girls you know
Sebastian is that you hey what's going
on okay who's this
one I know Sebastian in the end I wasn't
woman enough for you no you weren't and
that's just something I'll always have
to live
with it's a very funny cut too yeah
never forget you Sebastian MH ever
[Music]
never also I feel like there shooting
this at bug
too I can see that you got some pizza
there hey there pretty lady Miss virgin
rer I'm looking for my boyfriend
Sebastian Hastings have you guys seen
him that guy just shot himself let her
get too close she'll recognize you what
am I going to
doas keep away from me I beg your pardon
pretty ladies what are you talking about
talk to you crazy crazy and when my eyes
are closed I see you for what you truly
are which is
ugly we're
[Applause]
done the accent is killing me I'm like
it changes every five minutes and it's
it's funny oh my God she's on our class
quit blushing that's lame shut up not
blushing
everyone take us slip and read off the
name of your lab partner Unice
bites Olivia
Lennox oh you know her talked to her for
like a second about what she gave you
the nod D yeah she did a good one too
yeah she gives good nod you good N I
don't think we introduced ourselves
before I'm Sebastian Olivia I'm going to
be the best laugh partner you ever had
cool just just reel it back a little
bit let's just turn it down no paper
near the bunson burner okay oh wait
what's this poems lyrics they're his my
old stuff wake up I've been waiting for
you the music Q is so good these are
really good my God it's magical so
honest so raw mhm this is perfect you
can convince her to go out with me you
do this I'll work with you on your
soccer I'll make you good enough to make
first string you got a deal you're the
man yes I am they said they said the
thing kind of he
said what did you why are you sitting
there what did you expect yeah what did
you expect to happen like come on
now hey hey hey hey hey go Amanda go
Amanda get it
bindes
over oh
right the love of God it burns it burns
it burn three years for Olivia and then
some transfer student comes in and
suddenly she's acting like some obsessed
Love Struck teenager I'm not going to
take that lying down molio bro how'd you
get that pillow
made I'll do some digging I'll find out
what it is and I'll nip his chance with
Olivia right in the butt in the butt oh
oh yeah sure walk sorry come on you are
so smart oh my God what a
creeper he's a future um serial murderer
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm still little
FL did you come school yeah I did it's
uh all taken care of just make sure
you're back by the so come over he just
like he's the counselor he cleans
Windows he also serves lunch this man is
everywhere what trouble with your wig
Hastings uh no um I actually I have a
scalp condition no you don't you've got
male pattern
baldness okay there's going to be a time
when you're going to have to come out of
the closet and just accept yourself for
who you are a
Baldi and between you and me chicks dig
it
R have you ever thought about going out
with Duke orino no yeah yeah no no no
yeah so you're telling me he's not just
another dumb jock who wants to hook up
with me so he can tell all of his
friends but to insecure to treat you as
an equal exactly I think you're the
first guy at the school who hasn't tried
anything with me trust me you're not my
dipe oh we're friends you know then just
take my advice go out with Duke I'll
consider it she just wants you more now
yeah she's not going to give
up okay who's your Daddy I got her
degree to consider you your hway and men
men I'm not really good at talking to
girls why you're hot what you're an
appealing guy man look I I don't know I
just always say the wrong thing I want
to try something where I'm going to act
like a girl and you're going to talk to
me I'm fola Duke nice to meet you okay
that was creepy you really just sounded
like a girl just
then I'm
Viola ask me some questions and if the
chemistry is right things I'll just
start
flowing God are they going to like
accidentally kiss in this scene I
wouldn't be surprised no they're going
to get close to kissing
and I like G too see see what we're
flowing we're talking about cheese so
what flow is blue what what's that oh
it's
malvolio the
[Music]
guy
they do play with fun camera angles in
this movie like during crazy time oh
there it happened which is great you
don't ever ever do that girl voice again
freak me out turn me
on Sebastian honey this is your mother I
mind you about the carnival tomorrow
your mom's in junior leag yeah so is
mine Olivia's going to be there Olivia's
going to be there and my sister and
Mo'Nique and you we love the
inconsistent accents yeah I mean it's
like all over the
place never really like Carnival hey I'm
working the kissing booth come see me oh
hey girl hey I will just say I would not
want to work the kissing
booth that mean she has to kiss all the
people that come and there's not a lot
that I want to kiss so I'd be like no no
no no unless you're allowed to deny
almost
everyone in only kiss come to REO
yeah nope test your chances
nope you come on all right
$25 hi M you look like such a lady you
have the next shift at the kissing booth
and where's your brother I'm going to go
look for him oh my God we're doing this
I guess so I miss you we need to talk
we've talked Justus all the Talking is
done no one breaks up over a stupid
soccer issue okay can you just that guy
is not like he's High School no and he's
also popping his collar which I don't
think happens at
18 look
at oh God all right slaper Roy is that
an older guy thing or early 2000s thing
I don't
know do you guys still do that popping
the collar yeah I haven't seen I haven't
seen a popped collar in a while it's
been a spell maybe it was like a 2000s
thing there's been a there's been a
caller down spell that we're in now but
maybe we'll pop it back up hey maybe the
the rise of the pop collar will
return no one over 8 years old is
allowed inside the moon
bouns don't
look are you really trying to change in
there when it's like
open didn't she just changed I don't
know and now she's back to the girl but
I'm wondering why well you're changing
in front of all the kids after 4 years
Duke is finally going to fulfill his
destiny life is good it's too long why
did you sign up for this oh my God why
do people no just push him this is not
cool this is just um I'm your really and
yet I can't catch a break beware the old
guy chewing gum it's not gone ew it's
just my luck no no no no I mean I didn't
I didn't mean it like that it's just you
know she's I mean on the on on the other
hand you're I am thanks I
guess my goodness I maybe I should kiss
you now I guess that girl my ticket and
I I waited in line at least I can
do okay you know where this is
[Music]
heading yeah she likes it okay I think
that was one ticket go a little bit
more the hell is this making out my
girlfriend exgirlfriend you're
Sebastian's sister and you're about to
die what are you going to do drown me in
your tears I did not cry during that
game I had something in my
eye just dial it down and just step away
okay you know what she's right I'm going
to see you on the soccer field and we'll
settle this all then yeah man settle it
on the
field punch
him yeah now we're into another Montage
she got to change her clothes while they
fight oh no she she's still there I know
she's still there what's going on don't
you have to change it to the guy now yet
you the perfect distraction yeah and you
come back and then you're like no man
guys come on we got to go play soccer
yeah she has to be the guy to break up
the fight then she has to CH back change
back into the girl to do the kissing
booth
yep pop there is no room for violence
fall with your mouth open I guess so
where were you at today you just
disappeared ran into my psycho X had the
bolt oh my god oh yeah yeah call back
you're right by the way these things
actually work I got into it with your
sister's ex why he saw me and her making
out the kissing booth you kissed her I
hope that's okay it was for charity dude
you want to kiss her you go right ahead
and you kiss her oh my goodness you take
her and then kiss her and then kiss the
crap out of her okay Break On
Me Maybe you should ask her out and just
I don't know for forget about Olivia I
am not sure that you and Olivia really
mesh well together you and
Viola be magic you really that
something what does your heart tell you
I mean which one would you rather see
naked she sprung off of one kiss yeah
why do you always talk about girls in
such graphic terms you're a really
sensitive guy look I just think that a
relationship should be more than just
the physical stuff when I'm with someone
I want to be able to talk about other
stuff I serious stuff we feel like this
is very Advanced for 2000s
right I just told you it's for your ears
only if you tell anyone I'll kick your
ass I got your back
man why is that creeper who is in love
with the blonde girl taking pictures of
them now weird very weird maybe he's
stalking him because he knows that he's
pursuing the blonde chick oh how's your
sister good why I don't know been
thinking about her she wanted to grab
dinner at cesarios tonight really I'd
love to
Hastings yeah yeah coach your first
string for the Cornwall game really no I
was joking you idiots
what a oh no he okay sarcasm
my
goodness yeah yeah we're Bros yeah isn't
he cute dup yeah no Sebastian he's so
cool but he said I'm not his type make
him jealous so what do you do you just
pretend to like somebody else MH
wow my God so emotionally unavailable
not even walking on the treadmill she
was just standing
there Sebastian Olivia Olivia what do
you bench foress in these days Duke
225 thanks so so Duke about that call
that you're going to make you going to
make that yeah
than like 20 20 225 is more than twice
what I weigh how many reps could you do
with me
40 hello hi it's viola fashion told me
to call you I'd love to go to dinner
yeah what can I call you back so
aggressive I know the gym and also they
don't hear her making that call like 3
feet
away oh my bad cesarios 8:00 I'll see
you there bye Sebastian later later
hottest
girl came up you and asked you on
a right back Olivia oh wow can I talk to
you for a second uh Mah whatever
for you're right he's awesome he's not a
piece of meat he's a man a man with
feelings and I'm a woman with feelings
and my feelings seem to match his such
an interesting love triangle I'm not so
sure that you and Duke are a good idea
after all you're so worried maybe you
should come to Cesario tonight we could
double I bet Unice is available I'm so
there it's insane huh
isn't it great to have a real man around
Unice oh
yes Sebastian's with Unice she must be
hard than I thought she was okay how
come when I wanted to ask how unit
everyone made fun of me but now
Sebastian likes her and suddenly she's
cool this is almost like a TV sitcom but
it's put into a movie oh totally right
it's very situational comedy yeah this
been real fun but I have to go yeah it's
totally a TV plot this has been lovely
um let's do it again some time what soon
do you like cheese more than almost any
other animal
byproduct girl chill I love Unice hey
manique it's Sebastian I don't know if
Iola told you I'm in London but I'm
heading home a day
early today we're going to go over the
guidelines for a
graceful junk you guys she is also in
Virgin River the TV show I'm like who
casted this and who cast that TV show I
need to know what's the connection this
is all coming together cuz this movie is
old you really like that show
they I barely watch it but they're both
in it and that's crazy to me cuz this is
like shot a million years
agoa
darling remember Sho like you have a
secret you like you have a secret is
that a thing you say that I have never
heard that but I'm going to use it I'm
going to use it
now you went out with that Duke orino
guy right yeah once did you kiss him no
why try to postpone it he has this uh
salivary gland condition she don't even
want
him actually I don't really like to I
have this huge thing for his roommate
Sebastian and I was just trying to make
Sebastian jealous see like nowadays she
would be like oh like they would make
her like bye right like Amanda Vine's
character like she wouldn't be so like
oh
crap you are weaving a really dangled
web yeah like really really Tangled and
um you got to stop tell her the truth
yeah the next time I see Sebastian I'm
going to March right up to him just be
honest dude like you're making it more
complicated than it has to be I'm going
to kiss him so passionately that even
the people he hates will feel
pleasure I am Sebastian's girlfriend
exgirlfriend oh you were the one who
dumped in the pizza parlor the other
day guys when is glitter eyeliner coming
back cuz she has it you need to bring it
back ter start I will I will I'll give
it a I'll give it a shot all right next
video I see some eyeliner messing with
the wrong
man oh
go this is all so
unnecessary and it's all over a
[Music]
man ow when debutants
disagree they say it with their
eyes we say it passive aggressively he's
hiding something he may be a little lost
and confused but deep down he's an
All-American red blooded male just like
yourself oh I was wrong trying to spy on
a mandin yes oh wait he actually has a
Ducati okay I got a
Ducati don't forget your guitar Mr
Hastings just close your eyes and kiss
him oh she going to kiss the real one
the real brother I've been waiting for
you to open your eyes so I can tell you
that I think I'm ready I'm ready to free
fall into the unknown oh God I'll see
you the game tomorrow I think I'm going
to like this
school but I'm heading home a day early
London dingles just looking for me you
know it's um crazy how wrong you can can
be about a person you didn't even know
that was him I saw you kissing him when
you got out the cat me I never lik you
okay Viola she's crazy about you I bet
that's part of your little plan you and
your sister have a good luck all right
you just took the wig off you could have
just been honest yeah let's get down to
it Sebastian open up he's not here take
his stupid cell phone this isn't
Sebastian's phone
Sebastian e she said ew to him hello
Viola hey baby it's Viola allow me to
introduce myself what oh my
goodness wow by you set up all my
stuff thanks this is where it all blows
up boom Bastion the game's about to
start get out of bed and get over to
soccer field
[Applause]
man why didn't you wake me you looked so
Serene I made breakfast
darling what's un's story when don't we
get the Unice spin-off I would be
interested in that she's never kissed
anyone never kissed anybody real aggro
who's going to bring that blood and pain
black and this ain't going to be no game
this is a war who's going to bring that
blood and
pain who who who
yeah
keep you my dirty little secret dirty
little
secret regret oh my god get back in here
get the oh my god this is my game what
the hell am I doing here this isn't
[Music]
Fun can I get a timeout please going to
try to pull off Sebastian's hair but
it's the real Sebastian is there a
problem principal yes unfortunately
there is but I think it's only write
that Sebastian Hastings tell you himself
how does nobody realize that it's not
the same person they look nothing
literally not the same person I am
grievously sad uhoh to inform you that
Sebastian Hastings is a girl he's
actually specifically his own sister
Biola who's been impersonating him I'm a
boy prove it show shows show it off nice
work
Paul now that we've established this boy
is a boy is it possible we can get back
to our
game work Hastings bench
bench get it why are you wearing my
uniform I just came here to find the
amazing girl that kissed me last night
that one
Olivia okay come on Coach give me one
more chance all right go nobody notices
they look different or that they're not
the same hype nope all right nobody body
notices that's
Viola kick it to our
goal yeah
nice sick gold all right
man give me the
ball hey over
here wa she going to have her big moment
to prove herself we're all waiting she
needs to break the tie and end up being
like uhoh uhoh I'm a girl I'm good at
sports she has to get her last shot
being a
woman can you just throw students is
that allowed I guess all right get out
of my Stadium otherwise get him with a G
all right come on now where's the other
team's coach exactly wasn't he in the
the stands okay no Olivia not now want
you try to tell me again how there's
nothing going on between you there is
nothing going on between me and Olivia
come out real Sebastian come out I
didn't lie to you duke I did but not
about this here's the truth I love you
oh
God what I'm not Sebastian I'm Viola I
know Viola I I kissed Viola you kissed
me you kiss me please girl take your wig
off already apparently they can't C see
through it been pretending to be my
brother while he was in London for the
past 2 weeks so I can make the team and
beat Cornwall not the not the I Love You
Hell
Mary
but my brother came home early and
that's who you saw kissing Olivia and
that's who played the first half just
because you wear a wig doesn't prove
you're a girl okay
then we you showing we you showing okay
is it just me or does this soccer game
have more nudity wrong all so everybody
understand that guy just happen to look
like the other guy if I kissed your
brother where is he probably halfway to
China by now he showed his Willis and
doodleberry pres ladies and gentlemen I
hate to say I told you so but
I I just wanted to prove that I was good
enough all I'm asking for is a chance
with him or for the game both it's just
like what coach says before every game
be not afraid of greatness some are born
great some achieve greatness when did
she take the gauze off that's what I
want to some have greatness thrust upon
them I think the best chance for us to
be great here today is to have you play
okay all right I was wrong but I knew
she was going to do the final shot as a
girl yes I had to there's no girls in
this league here look in the
manual we don't discriminate based on
gender all right that's going to
bruise you really think you can beat us
with a girl on your team who this guy
bro this guy who's this clown he's
exhausting let's go kick
[Applause]
Ki get it Amanda bines get it or
Viola we you going to kick it right here
aren't you I know you're going to K
right in your your head right in your
dumb old face Bud getting smaller knock
him out she going to hit him in the
peeee come on
now
nice back to the
kick I got beat by a girl way to go you
did
it wow that that was really
something I just realized we haven't
seen the dad the whole movie huh right
right not until right now why don't we
go to dinner as a family maybe tomorrow
call her
up it's a thing there's somebody I want
you to officially meet Sebastian
Hastings Olivia
L they're going to make out now on the
field maybe but after he yells at her a
little
[Laughter]
bit this is Raya Montaine I know this
song I do know I do
not this is for
you
M
yeah oh no that's not the
words go cheese sweet Jes Junior League
invite you to the 38th annual the
debutant ball you'll see her and fall in
love with her I found the perfect dress
I don't think I'm going to get a chance
to wear it nonsense you don't need a man
to wear a beautiful dress
M hi so what brings you here Amanda our
love binds us that good on I kissed this
girl I just can't seem to stop thinking
about it I should have told you who I
was but was afraid maybe if I have known
you were a girl we wouldn't have talked
like we did everything would just be a
lot easier if you stayed a
girl mon Valentine a Olivia Lennox
escorted by Sebastian
Hastings everybody get someone Viola
Hastings oh she's in green and they're
making out in front of
everyone cuz she's the
woman
yay a happy ending for every one
oh this song I know this
[Music]
song also don't know the
words I know the
song I kind of know the r roll the
credit now
we just watch she's a
man keep it strong Move Along along know
you do move
along what just happened oh cuz we're on
we're on the Netflix we're on the Flix
get out of here Netflix She's All That I
seen that one either I think that's
another mandab bin I think I have seen
that I just forgot about it oh the she's
all that and he's all that oh there's
like a whole thing huh it's a whole
thing you see the the f I see it oh I
see it y I've never seen 13 Going on 30
either I don't think I have either oh
wait wait Tera maybe I have have you
seen the notebook yes duh I haven't seen
the notebook oh my God I love the I want
to watch The Notebook oh I love the
notebook it's so good damn it listen we
have to talk about che's the man cuz
it's a movie we just just watched so do
you have thoughts or what I do have
thoughts I do have opinions about this
movie um it was fun it was very 2000s
very very very uh um was cheese it was
it was a very Amanda bines and very
tanning Tatum um it was you know listen
I I thought it was
lighthearted campy good old classic
early 2000 fun yeah uh it's it's like a
little harmless movie you know no one's
going to get mad over she's the man no
one's going to be up in arms it's just
like a you know it's a classic movie
that I know a lot of people who grew up
in the mid to early 2000s kind of grew
up on and yeah I missed this movie as a
child but I'm happy that I've seen it
now cuz now I can if people make
references to this movie I Now
understand them and yeah I thought it
was it was a fun old time it was a good
old time that that's the opinions I have
in the meantime T what did you think of
the movie I mean I had fun too but there
was there was something that uh was just
lacking a little bit was just the pace
because I was like wait these the things
that they were going through I was like
let's just like get to it but other
scenes I was like oh I'm super engaged
like with Channing Tatum awesome Amanda
B's accent going from I don't know Irish
to Southern to I don't even know what uh
did crack me up um Southern Irish to
like more traditional American like yeah
like that's that's great um uh yeah I
guess I guess to me I each scene sort of
individually was like oh this is fun but
I felt like I was watching a TV show but
it was like string together into a movie
so that made it a I guess a little less
engaging for me where I felt like oh
should there be a commercial break
now a little bit I don't I don't know
why um the pacing something about it
felt a little bit off but there are some
really like rewarding aspects of like
it's fun to see Amanda bind like she
goes like way quirky big huge broad
comedy of like a lot of faces and like
well I don't know man like what do you
um what do you think you you you like
you want to do you know and I feel like
that's a very romcom thing and that we
got a lot of that in the '90s and early
2000s but we don't really get that
anymore which is why I think this like
remains a classic there's probably ways
that there's movies that maybe have
played with this before and possibly
done a better job like the music cues in
this awesome right were like soundtrack
but some of them were supposed to be
real and I laughed when it would be like
a music queue going into to like make it
serious like I still thought it was
funny and I was like I don't know if
they were really trying to make us like
really feel something cuz during those
times I I was and I was like oh this is
funny I get what they're doing here um
but I mostly found this movie kind of
sitting on the surface uh yeah it like
it touched on the things that a premise
like this would would ask but didn't
really like dive into them which I don't
think it was it was trying to do that
also though I did have fun with the
movie I said it's like kind of a
harmless movie like it's something that
people grew up with like early 2000s
that um are like in the late to mid 20s
area at this point in life uh but I will
say uh this movie requires to forgive
requires you to forgive a lot or just
like kind of like not really think about
it because if you think about it too
hard it kind of falls apart uh the fact
that nobody caught her doing her
changing or the fact that she's like in
the mirror in the bathrooms or I don't
know just a lot a lot of different
scenarios and communication they do that
thing in movies where like this could
easily be solved with like a very simple
solution just being straightforward but
because you have to keep up the rules
for some reason it has to go further and
then more complications ensue because of
that fact so I will say that I I kind of
touch on that as we're watching the
movie but yeah I say that's my general
feelings in the meantime I think that uh
got to sit with a little bit more but I
think it was it was it was fine it was
it was fun like imagine if they squeezed
in like four of these scenes into a 45
minute episode you go that's good like
if they sped it up like we already know
what's going going to happen from the
start to the end and there was still
just some time and like the blonde girl
likes him and it's jealous and stuff in
the gym where you're like this feels
like it's taking like just a little too
long only because like the situational
comedy stuff we got a lot of it and I
felt like at a certain point in this
movie it started to play out a little
bit where I was like let's just get to
it but I feel like if somebody squeeze
certain scenes of this movie into 45
minutes you'd be like oh that was fun
like way more fun yeah I found it more
just like it I didn't feel like it was a
SLO to get through but I definitely
found it more just like kind of
entertaining or just like on this level
than I did like really funny cuz this
supposed to be a comedy and we did have
our laughs here and there but we didn't
laugh a lot it wasn't it wasn't like
what we ass what you would assume this
movie is of
like oh my gosh you know it was just
sort of like huh you know there's some
stuff that's that's uh laugh out loud
and in the beginning like Amanda binds I
was like wow that freaking accent is
Bonkers Wackadoo wild but all of it was
when they're put it it was such big
broad comedy that um some of it I was
like this is too big for what they're
doing right now and I don't know why
because broad comedy can work in the
right circumstances but with this movie
it it only did for me in some of the
circumstances and I'm not sure why that
may just be like pacing and tone and um
maybe the story of just like let's get
to it I don't know that they need did an
hour and a half for us to get from where
she started to where we ended it it was
like an hour 40 it was an hour and 40 45
something like that yeah yeah it's too
long it's too long like this should have
been 1:30 and maybe we would have been
like wow cuz if you could cut 15 minutes
off and you really like we we need to
like pump through these scenes a little
bit quicker I don't know that's just my
opinion I think it's interesting having
I don't know if this movie's PG did they
cuss it all in the movie I don't
remember think they did I feel like this
was a this feels like a PG-13 or a PG I
think this would be something that would
play on
Nickelodean does it say the rating oh
it's PG-13 pg-3 goofy Corky comedy I
feel like if this movie was made today
there'd be a lot more social commentary
peppered into it yeah and I feel like
she would be bisexual kind of how you
said totally like she'd probably look at
her like oh like wait you like me like
and she also likes a guy but she likes
the girl they would play with that right
what year did this come out
2004 does it
say it doesn't say say I think it was
early 2000s
though she's the
man 20 2006 200 oh wow 2006 okay okay
yeah that's still before all that the
social commentary like what you're
saying like we wouldn't have gotten
there yet yeah you know like um the most
recent one that comes to mind that we've
both seen independently but uh bottoms
yes oh God that movie peppered in with
the social commentary but also keeps
that Corky um feeling of a high school
experience alive so yeah it's it's
interesting that movies within the 2000s
era didn't really like they they had
Concepts they wanted to keep it on the
lighter side and I feel like maybe
because of that it comes across as a
little bit more fluffy which you know
there's nothing nothing wrong with that
I know a lot of people are really into
this movie but yeah I like I said I just
I liked it I didn't love it I didn't
think it was super duper funny but yeah
I I don't regret watching it it was yeah
it was an enjoyable experience and that
was kind of corny but yeah hey that's
that's the product of the times guys
yeah you guys know it listen we liked
watching this with you we love you leave
your leave your comments below let us
know what you liked about it um also yes
uh on top of what he was saying about
bottoms I think it's one of the best
movies of the year it's so freaking good
so comparing that's just like they're in
two different categories but if so if
you haven't watched it watch it but um
this was fun let us know what you guys
thought we love you uh you know all the
things get a real reject t-shirt if you
haven't already and do you have any last
words you'd like to say to the
people I thought she's the man you man
hey we did
it we love you guys and we will see you
on the next one
[Music]
bye